I would like as well we're gonna be
making pancakes without a recipe today
oh you're a mom I am red pen yeah I've
never made pancakes what any pancakes I
mean at stores I've never made a pancake
before but I feel pretty confident that
we can make something pancake adjacent
pancakes are really difficult to mess up
I'm confident they're like how bad can
we do cut to the failure whatever you
make I will try okay okay Wow it's kind
of fun to like go off the rails and try
something new best for you should we get
started yeah so we are gonna need with
flour whisks we're gonna need that one
measuring cup welcome you all girls are
so cute I love when you go like that and
you're like cooking yeah you look like a
chef we're gonna you actually use
measuring cups huh I have to or else I'm
not gonna get their ratios correct
oh well it's like somebody's talking
about ratios is that flour yeah that's
flour yeah I know you need flouring but
I'm gonna go a little more freewheeling
oh my gosh see he's gonna do that he's
gonna do better
whenever I'm careful I lose this isn't a
contest I don't know what order to do
this and I'm just doing it based on my
emotions do you mean egg yes I'll need
an egg can you crack it with one hand
oh no I suck at cracking Julia Child get
at me sugar is a wet ingredient I know
that sure is not a wet ingredient yeah
it is considered a wet ingredient is it
yeah I think I need baking so Todd sugar
I'm not telling you do you need one of
these guys just to get this out of here
but I'm not measuring I could confuse
TSP at this table or dougie spoons Oh
tbsps table Oh what's up cinnamon
because I liked it some cinnamon last
thing I'm gonna put in is the milk
I think that's my coffee Cal I'm glad
that like you have such faith in my
skills that you're like I'm just gonna
copy you this egg seems like it was a
lot of liquid I guess we can add more
flour to it grab with a hint of vanilla
because I know if you put too much it's
too strong it's a lot of vanilla okay
that's why it's so far and now I'm gonna
add milk until it's the consistency of a
pancake this is really thick you're
gonna need more little bit it was the
arm workout at a little um you don't I
really appreciate that you haven't given
up on me she's fantastic
you can do anything you believe in YB I
love you thank you yours looks a little
runny I'd be pretty embarrassed by it
yeah that feels like a pancake
consistency I think I did too many
chocolate chips I don't think that's
possible
that's too many chocolate a little bit
more milk oh that was a lot no have you
taste tested your batter yet I don't
taste tests with fraud
I'm gonna go rogue want to taste the
batter
I think I need a little more baking
powder oh I wouldn't shake it and I'd
use it yeah I know what you would do you
know what it doesn't have any salt
that's what it is
that's what it is it's never add it's
impossible people you got to put salt in
your cookies you got to put salt in your
pancakes it just keeps it that special
blah just gonna get a little better in
here you feel you wait till the bubbles
pop on the top and then you flip I'm a
big big pancake baby here we go the
sound it's supposed to make that's a
pickup yeah that's a big boy so there
was a bubble right there yeah it's gonna
pop it needs like a little bit more time
for a little vegetable spray like inside
yes oh wow Hannah those fine I made him
his name is Fred Fred's a pancake hmm
jiggling stuff all right my turn
yep go ahead I just spray no don't be
afraid to use this stuff you don't want
that sticking we go so you mean enough
for exactly one oh it looks a little
thin well maybe I can make it into a she
a really ugly your raisins kind of dark
in color nice and liquid in there it's
been good to it like sizzle it's not
like frying an egg be careful Oh quite
right yeah we'll flip it back it's too
big to put Chiwetel it harder me just
wants to help the part of me is like no
she should do it herself I think it's
just practice it's still on fire just a
broken home I'm a bird learning to fly
it's gonna make mistakes fine doesn't
look correct get it off me me get the
other side just a little bit you gotta
kiss it why does it look dry my it looks
like a really good first pancake why me
I know I'm proud
that's sweet satisfying yeah buddy whoo
the chocolate chips are newsn I'm gonna
dig in and try my pancake creation and
see if it measures up to the ones that
my mom used to make Cheers
there's solid oh my god this is good how
was yours
gummy it's not bad
mmm too salty it's your pancake it's not
right or wrong no it's wrong it's not
right it's wrong like that consistency
is like very motors yeah the I put too
much baking powder or a flower or
something it's not bad it's just weird
let's see I'll tell yours yeah that's
how pancake supposed to be friggin proud
of this pancake I would make this again
if someone served me that and they're
like this is what you get to you would
eat it I would be like just drink a lot
of milk with this I'm trying to actually
give the people an honest assessment of
my pancake wait let's just do a side by
side we learned a bit about pancake
making I think we didn't do any big
missteps you think you'll ever make it
on your pancake I think I could probably
be okay I'm making pancakes I mean I
think who's been eatin long you got good
impulses and that little sister do I are
you that's the first step right honestly
learning from other people yeah heard
from my mom so you're my mom now
[Music]